hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Sulman I've been like
dying to play this game by the way in
case you guys couldn't tell I'm the
super so hello is this hello buddy
should I free you probably not you have
a gun - the gun don't shoot me okay bye
am I supposed to follow you are you
following me
thanks a little buddy I don't like you
I'm gonna name you tiny sub Jim David
yeah I gotta be more original yeah
I can't just name him Tim I can't name
everything Tim I'm gonna name you bubble
butt cuz I like you
cuz you shoot bubbles out your button I
like that okay so I gotta get into there
come on bubble butt you want to come in
so excited okay both of us serious nice
like a bubble butt helping me out
thanks bubble bubble butt
I'll see you around hopefully
[Applause]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma
I'll never get why you don't need to be
such a pessimist about things you can do
it believe in yourself your thanks
Bubble Boy you're the best oh my gosh
are you gonna be following me around now
oh you're so cute I love your bubble but
always will like I said you're my little
bubble blowing bubble bug biscuit oh
you're so cute the tooltip is bust we
need to get a new tool chip and swish it
okay I think it would be easier to just
take one from the robot the tool box
over there says it has a stun baton you
could use that I am NOT knocking Bubble
Boy I'm sorry
I feel like a bad man but still here
[Music]
[Laughter]
you